operation christmas child it's supported
by samaritan's purse
and it provides christmas gifts for
millions of underprivileged children
all over the world it's amazing and so
of course it seems like an
unobjectionable cause doesn't it well
not
if you are a local atheist group looking
to ruin other people's christmases
now liberty middle school in kansas is
now canceling plans for students and
faculty
to participate in the program after
the freedom from religion foundation
filed a complaint
demanding that the school cease
participation or
taking any other actions promoting
christianity
joining me now is reverend franklin
graham president of samaritan's purse
the christian nonprofit
running the drive reverend uh that now
this complaint they do this
every easter and every christmas the
complaint says that this
drive violates basic constitutional
principles what's your reaction
you know we've been doing this for 27
years and
it's close to 200 million shoe boxes
that we have given out
we don't solicit necessarily from
schools anybody can participate and what
this is this is
just children they're at the school that
did this on their own and got their
school involved
and first of all i want to say thank you
to to the kids i want to say thank you
to everybody that's ever packed a
shoebox
and i want people to know that they're
at the liberty middle school
you can send your shoe boxes directly to
samaritan's purse and we'll still take
them
even though your school doesn't want to
participate you can participate
and laura this is a i want every child
that gets a box uh to know that god
loves them and that he cares for them
and and we don't hide the fact that
we're christians we don't
it's on our website we're very up front
about our our position and our faith
you see i believe that jesus christ is
god's son and
i believe he came at christmas that god
gave him
uh to this world and that if we would
just turn from our sins that god would
forgive our sins and heal our sins